they came from across the province
demanding peace from the Pakistani
government after Monday's suicide attack
on a mosque that killed 101 people and
injured many more political parties were
asked not to fly their Flags instead
White flags were raised many people here
in the northern city of bashawar say
they don't trust Pakistan's military
establishment but Stone region have been
suffering from 20 years
eight of the time that government should
provide us a peace and our own and our
last and ultimate demand is based on
this region this protest is seen as a
popular Uprising similar to the one that
followed the killing of 134 students in
2014 in a Taliban attack on a military
school the movement starved the
Pakistani Taliban of supporting towns
and villages in the region and along
with military operations attacks by the
Taliban drastically reduced he responds
that these kind of incidents are
happening but no one is taking
responsibility our women and children
are suffering we want peace we want
education we don't want state-sponsored
terrorism every house in this province
is bleeding and we can't take any more
bodies
they chant we will never accept
terrorism
the threat is still very real security
was high around the protest on Saturday
morning police carried out operations
against armed groups they say two
Taliban commanders were killed and
Acacia of weapons confiscated and others
were taken into custody
the targets of this terror group which
we Earnest Industries
were policemen key security
installations and some high-profile
persons in this region prime minister
Shahbaz sharifa said Pakistan is facing
an unimaginable economic challenge
the killing of over 100 people seems to
be a real Turning Point here in Pakistan
for years they struggled and suffered
with militancy and they don't want to
see it make a return but unlike before
the economic conditions now are the
worst the country has ever faced which
will make it even more difficult to get
vital resources that police so
desperately need but for people here
they don't have a choice they live on
the front line of this battle
Pakistan